there is a very interesting new poll
from fox news
that shows trump losing just about
everything and republicans losing a
whole bunch of stuff
in november now normal caveats one poll
doesn't tell us anything
we don't go by the polls we go by votes
which is why no matter what the polls
say
you go and vote um fox news polling
is not the same as tucker carlson right
fox news polling is actually
uh quite well rated and the actual
field work for fox news polling is done
by other companies that are hired by fox
news so
fox news polling is relatively good okay
what does this poll say
well first of all incumbent republican
senators
are losing significantly in
arizona and north carolina donald trump
is losing nationally and in some key
battleground states but let's
let's be thorough here first of all is
the methodology of this fox news poll
solid it is uh it's very popular to say
who's picking up landlines these days
these polls only
they're only talking to landlines wrong
this
is a poll mostly of cell phones with
some
landlines it distinguishes between their
overall sample
and the fine-tuned likely voter model
which has a 3.5 point
margin of error that's normal than to be
expected so the methodology is good
on trump versus biden among likely
voters
joe biden is up 9 49 to 40. among
registered voters joe biden is up 10 49
to 39 so
that's very close the fact that it's not
that it's not a big difference between
registered voters and likely voters
suggests that the people who are
actually planning to vote
are roughly representative of all adults
who are registered
to vote now on the issues donald trump
in this poll is still winning on the
economy but just barely
barely in some polls trump is now losing
on the economy
in this one he's winning but only by one
45 to 44
and he's losing on every other major
issue uh trump is losing by one to biden
on who would better deal with china
trump is losing by five to biden on who
would better handle
policing and criminal justice and on
coronavirus
which is in poll after poll the issue
for voters
donald trump is trailing joe biden by
17.
let's now look at those senate numbers
because as many of you are emailing me
correctly assessing almost as important
at changing the figurehead at the top
meaning the president
is looking at taking the senate from
republicans so they can
stop putting in judges so that they can
stop obstructing
sensible reforms to so many aspects of
our economy and our society and our
country so
there's a few really good senate numbers
for democrats
in arizona we've got senator i'm sorry
democratic challenger mark
kelly up against incumbent senator
martha mcsally
mark kelly is leading by 17
among likely voters 56 to 39
just one poll you want to take an
average of polls
to get a more precise assessment but
plus 17 is a shocking number
in a state that was a red state for
a long time now the numbers for north
carolina senate
are from a different fox news poll also
released yesterday the democratic
challenger there is cal cunningham
leading the incumbent republican senator
tom tillis by 6 48 to 42
now that's still going to be an uphill
battle the challenger being below 50
means that when you have 10 percent of
the electorate
saying i'm either undecided or third
party
often they will coalesce around the
incumbent so that
we have to fight that one but it is a
great sign
just two months out in north carolina
and then
stunning numbers from wisconsin where
donald trump is now down by
eight in this poll 50-42
remember that in 2016 in wisconsin it
was less than one point
separating donald trump and hillary
clinton i think it was about
0.7 0.8 donald trump of course
ultimately winning in wisconsin and that
was one of the places where monday
morning quarterbacking the election we
heard frequently
hillary didn't go she didn't even go to
wisconsin fair criticism at the time
among others
we will see uh joe biden in wisconsin i
believe today
if not tomorrow so what do we do
in light of these numbers you know the
answer we vote
that's it if you go and look at the 538
projection for 2020 it still says
ominously that 70 chance of a biden win
and 29 chance of a trump win are the
current numbers
those are the same numbers that hillary
versus trump had
in this projection in 2016
it means either person could win and it
means every vote needs to be
cast and it means you need a plan for
how to vote again we have resources that
we have been posting
on usa.gov and vote.org
figure out if you are registered what is
your polling place
is there early voting how do you
register for an absentee ballot how do
you track the status
of your absentee ballot have a plan we
can't take anything for granted but this
one fox news poll and again the senate
we're really looking at that senate
where democrats need to pick up
a few seats and if we lose the alabama
seat the doug jones seat
that'll be one extra seat that needs to
be picked up to take control
there is a path there is a path to
democrats taking the senate
and if democrats were to take the senate
keep the house and defeat donald trump
it would be one of the
biggest uh uh defeats for the republican
party
in history making a president a one-term
president is tough
bill clinton did it to george h.w bush
but
it is not super common the power of
incumbency
is called the power because it is
powerful
uh we've got a lot to do we've got a lot
to work on phone banking get out the
vote so on and so forth we'll be here
with you
uh through and beyond the election
make sure you're getting the daily audio
podcast carry it around with you in your
pocket
on any one of your favorite podcasting
apps be it itunes
spotify stitcher pandora
google play and let me know what you're
seeing in your state on twitter
where you can find me at deepakman
one of our sponsors today is vincero
watches
and they're giving you 15 off everything
in the store
when you go to davidpakman.com watch
if you're a guy looking for the perfect
way to refresh your style
one of the best investments you can make
is in a high quality
wrist watch vincero is an american
company
that has made it possible for everyday
people to afford
a premium watch almost everything they
sell is within the range of about 200
dollars but it'll look
like you spent a lot more all of their
watches are made in small batches from
top quality materials
and they just look great i went on their
site and picked out
a watch from their icon automatic
collection the one i got is in mesh
matte black and i love it it's simple
sleek elegant
goes great with just about anything i'm
wearing and i've gotten a ton of
compliments on it
you'll get 15 percent off everything in
their store
when you go to davidpakman.com watch and
i've put that link right underneath this
video